[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Hello.
Let's talk about API
program governance.
What is governance,
and more importantly,
how would that apply
to your API program?
Governance is defined
as to rule and control.
But in our fast
paced environment
where innovation
is key to attaining
that competitive
edge, heavy ruling
can control or slow down things.
And slowing things down,
progress can be impeded.
Governance when applied
to the API first model
is a balancing act.
We need to manage
risk while enabling
speed and agility in order
to meet the consumer's needs.
We don't want heavyweight
authority, control,
or regulation, and this is
why we call it a little g.
Finding the balance depends
on your organization:
startup versus traditional
enterprise, risk appetite
versus speed requirement.
Let's talk about the
keys to managing risk
while still maintaining the
ability to meet market needs.
The balance comes from an
intersection of 4 components.
First are the key roles
within an API team.
Second is the structure
of the team focused
on the digital initiative.
Third is the ownership
of the API products,
and the fourth and
final component
are the simple guidelines and
structures around the platform
for ease of adoption.
As mentioned in the previous
video around API team
composition, it is essential
to have an API team
leader who is aligned with
both the business and IT.
This role is called
the API product owner,
and it is a key
component to ensuring
that the APIs built target
a priority business outcome.
Central team defines API
development standards
and developed APIs based on
the requirements from product,
project, and
business unit teams.
This model allows for
consistency and development,
approach, and adherence.
However, this model
lacks the agility
that some of the
other models have.
A decentralized operating model
has the agility and the speed,
but lacks the standards
and common development
best practices.
This combined with a
lack of clear ownership
after the APIs are
released showcases
how different this model
is compared to that
of the centralized model.
So now we arrive at
the hybrid model.
This model possesses
the speed and agility
of the decentralized model
while also maintaining
a close adherence to standards.
The downside is that
a lot of coordination
is needed when it comes
to the requirements
across multiple teams.
So who owns which APIs?
Ownership of the APIs,
or the components
that make up those APIs, is
dependent upon the operating
model.
For example, in a hybrid
model, the platform team
is responsible for setting
guidelines, standards,
and the reusable assets.
Reusable assets are in the
form of shared flows or shared
services that adhere to a common
practice such as security,
traffic management,
or air handling.
This frees up the
specific product, project,
and business unit teams
to focus on API supporting
their business objectives.
Delivery can be much
faster when the teams don't
have to worry about the
standards for common assets.
Reusable assets can be
selected from an a la carte
menu to include in the
delivery team's API product.
Big G Governance is what
most companies end up with.
This assumes that
the teams are not
trusted to do the right thing,
and result in heavy gating.
Committees like
change approval boards
are formed to manually
audit any change that
are pushed to deployed systems.
Policies and procedures are
written into heavyweight Word
documents, and teams are split
by function, as they are not
trusted to work together.
Little g governance is harder
for an organization to swallow,
as responsibility
and accountability
is pushed down to where the
decision needs to be made.
It provides enough
governance to keep
the teams on the right path, but
doesn't seek to slow delivery.
Now let's run through
an analogy of a freeway.
While you're on a
freeway, the direction
is set, but can be
changed at junctions.
Guard rails helped keep cars
on the right side of the road
and traveling safely
in the right direction.
Lanes are painted to suggest
the right way to drive,
but can be crossed if needed.
The emphasis here is
on keeping the flow.
Now imagine if big
government was in control.
Every time you needed to
accelerate, slow down, change
lanes, or even change
direction, someone else
would need to have to
review that decision
and approve it for you.
Now imagine what that
would do to traffic.
Little g governance provide
standards principles
and best practices.
Teams are trusted and empowered
through tooling and automation.
Information and documentation
is shared collaboratively.
Teams are cross-functional
to minimize handoff
and communication issues.
Going back to the
freeway analogy,
little g governance operates
how we think of freeways today.
Organizations have hierarchy.
What tends to happen is that we
push information to authority.
The people at the bottom
have the information,
but they don't have the
authority to make the decision.
This results in
bottlenecks and delays.
We create systems that
channel information up,
where decision is
then taken, and then
that information
comes back down again.
As you can imagine, this
tends to take a lot of time.
And alternative is pushing
authority to the information.
The foundation for this
model is making sure
that the people that are
closest to the information
are both technically
competent and have
organizational clarity.
They understand the
priorities and know
what the right thing to do.
They are empowered to make the
decisions, and as a result,
they are happier for it.
If your organization
is truly undergoing
a digital transformation,
it is deeper
than building a mobile
app or putting some APIs
on a developer portal.
Think about why your company
started this initiative
in the first place.
If the benefits include reducing
costs and accelerating time
to market, then
the initiative has
to go well beyond that
of just building APIs.
To achieve those aims,
imposing a heavy weight process
that encourages blind
compliance with no room
to accelerate delivery will
at best slow, or at worst,
stop the benefits
of the program.
To achieve those aims,
imposing a heavy weight process
that encourages blind
compliance with no room
to accelerate delivery will
at best slow, or at worst,
stop the benefits
of the program.
Much of the time
governance, processes
are imposed top down, and
borne out of quick resolutions
to problems encountered.
The gates imposed often
have documentation
required at each
stage, which are
slow to produce, and discourage
effective communication
between teams.
Ultimately, the focus is
on the process protecting
the organization from the
IT teams, who they don't
trust to do the right thing.
This is done so rather than
accelerating business outcomes
in a safe manner.
So how do we apply this to
the API governance model?
If a centralized team
have all the authority,
then we can't scale, and
agility is inhibited.
We must give developers,
publishing or consuming APIs,
the information
and knowledge they
need to publish and use
those APIs thank you.